welcome back are you having trouble
trying to lose weight you can't get rid
of that stubborn fat well Dr Nash and
Total Transformation the sponsors of
this next segment have the solution take
a look at their success stories
Dr Nash welcome to the show I'm going to
jump right into it 14 years ago you lost
80 pounds you look beautiful today
you've kept the weight off how did you
do it I did it by focusing on those
underlying issues see for me it wasn't
just calories in calories out that got
me a result but it was always temporary
the permanent result came when I tackled
those metabolic issues under the surface
that makes the weight problem so
stubborn and we're going to look at some
people today who did the same thing yes
we are and we're going to start with one
of your clients Patrice take a look with
Dr Nash I've lost over 20 pounds and 30
inches and I'm still losing a pound a
day Patrice lost 20 pounds and 30 inches
tell us more isn't that crazy so Patrice
is a performer this is somebody who gets
on stage for a living who's a singer who
has people looking at her body as well
as listening to her voice and of course
she wants to feel self-confident when
she's on stage and Performing and that
weight was just for her holding her back
and she went after it the Vengeance we
found the underlying issues and 30
inches off her body I mean she shrunk
dramatically when she used these
strategies to fix that weight problem
there's a glow about her there's a
special glow about her let's take a look
at Desiree on Dr Nash's program I have
lost over 40 inches my energy level is
through the roof and my mental fog is
gone 40 inches tell us more Dr Nash so
this is a common thing that we hear a
lot where a woman is like obviously she
does raise a beautiful woman but after
she had children her body was struggling
to lose the weight even though she was
applying her old techniques they weren't
working we found out that she actually
had hormonal problems dietary hormone
problems inflammation when we went after
that bam 40 inches off and she just
she's rocking it now well she says do
more energy and the thing too that jumps
out that mental fog that she had it's
gone yeah that happens a lot with these
metabolic issues they just interfere
with you your abilities or your brain's
ability to think clearly and we don't
realize how much that's related to the
food that we're eating more energy less
mental fog this is fantastic let's take
a look at Meredith she lost 30 pounds
which jumping out to me is her stomach
it's gone it's flat so she lost those 30
pounds during the lockdowns and this was
at a time where we couldn't go out we
couldn't go anywhere so the reason we
like to show her is because while we do
want people to be active the exercise is
not the main driving Point behind that
weight issue every time you come on the
show you have a special what do you got
for us today I do normally the
evaluation that I have to do beforehand
to find out what the damage is that's 97
but when I get to talk about my program
on Las Vegas now they're always kind to
me that let me bring in a special so we
have 10 spots available for 9.97 they
are available online only to call my
office they're going to try to take a
hundred dollars from you but those spots
sell out quickly so drnash.com forward
slash eval secure your spot now if you
want to fix this problem for good
all right Las Vegas now we will be right
back